It's game show week, Ross.
And to celebrate we're gamifying the news.
Are you ready?
Oh, I'm ready.
It's Pop Culture Showdown!
Yes!
(upbeat music)
And we're the contestants today.
Oh, and it is on, Drew.
I'm so excited.
We're gonna play with each other.
And every game show needs a host.
And I know a host who's the most qualified
when it comes to pop culture, or anything else in the biz.
He's the host of "Entertainment Tonight",
now in its 40th season.
Please welcome our friend, Kevin Frazier!
Hi Kevin!
Drew, how are you?
Oh Kevin, I love how...
Hey Ross.
Hi, I love you.
(Ross giggles)
This makes me so happy, Kevin, thank you.
I am so excited to be a game show host right now, Drew.
All right, well before we play,
you brought us an amazing clip from the "ET" archives.
Take it away, Kevin.
Tell us who it is.
Yeah, Bob Barker, because the "Price is Right"
is the longest running game show on TV.
And Bob hosted it for almost 35 years,
starting all the way back in 1972.
He is the greatest of all time,
the GOAT is we like to say.
And when the American TV icon sat down with "ET",
back in 1986, he talked about why games
and game shows have such staying power.
Check this out.
Well, I believe that Americans are game oriented.
We play games at home as children, preschool children.
Families play games together.
They play games as they travel
in automobiles or on airplanes.
And we play games on social occasions.
And games were popular on radio many years ago.
And it was only a natural transition to television.
Okay.
I love him.
We love games!
That's what he told us.
And because we love games we're gonna play.
You both love pop culture.
And we're about to put that to the test, all right.
I get a little competitive, Kevin.
We're going to confer with each other
and then tell Kevin the answer, right?
Okay, understood.
Okay, perfect, got it.
Here's the first question.
Warner Brothers just announced "Wonka",
a prequel to "Charlie and the Chocolate Factory".
Who is reportedly pegged to follow up
Johnny Depp as the new Wonka?
Is it Timothee Chalamet, Donald Glover, or Florence Pugh?
Okay, I do not know this answer.
I don't either and I'm so mad that I don't.
Okay, lock us in on A, Timothee.
You're going to go with Timothee, A.
Yeah.
You are right!
(everyone cheering)
Timothee Chalamet is the answer.
Now, let me just say this.
There is some talk that Tom Holland could be a part of this.
It's a prequel, as I mentioned, and Warner Brothers
just announced it will be released in 2023.
So get ready for that, okay.
Hurry, we need that.
Question two.
This actor just revealed to the world
we've been calling them by the wrong name.
Is it Cate Blanchett, her actual name's Cate Blanket?
Anne Hathaway, she's an Annie, not an Anne?
Or Dwayne the Rock Johnson, he actually prefers the Stone?
I like the Rock's jacket there.
I'm just focusing on what's important.
I'm gonna lock in--
Is it B?
It's B.
Ha!
It's B, I saw this on a headline somewhere online.
Right?
You are on the money.
It is B, Anne Hathaway.
Anne Hathaway wants to be called Annie from now on.
When she got her SAG card back when she was 14 years old
she put Anne in there and everybody's called her Anne since.
But the only person who really calls her Anne
is her momma when she's mad.
Call her Annie from now on.
Here we go, question number three.
You guys are on fire right now.
What celeb couple recently welcomed a new baby named Khai.
Is it Gigi Hadid and Zayn Malik,
Sophie Turner and Joe Jonas,
Justin Timberlake and Jessica Biel?
Drew?
Let's go with A.
Are you going with A?
Yup, we're going with A.
We're locking in.
You got it right, it is A!
(everyone cheering)
Okay, so here's the deal.
We are so good at this.
Gigi's baby baby girl is named Khai.
And she didn't make a big announcement,
she just changed her Instagram handle to Khai's mom,
and everybody hopped on it.
Okay, that is the cutest thing I've ever heard.
I love that.
Isn't that cool?
Okay, we have one last question.
Take it away, Kevin.
Here we go, okay.
What Disney star's hit single is currently
the most listened to song on the planet?
Is it Demi Lovato, Sabrina Carpenter, or Olivia Rodrigo?
C!
We're cool, we know what the kids like.
We just talked about her all week last week.
You are right, her single just debuted at number one.
It has more than 58 million views on YouTube.
The official video, people are losing their minds
and going crazy.
All right, hey listen, that's our game.
But you guys were perfect, four for four,
you were on the money.
You are winners here!
Yes!
At the Pop Culture Showdown.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Kevin.
Please let's do this again
because this was the best fun ever.
And I hear that you have a little clip maybe for us
to send us off?
I do.
Well before we go, I do wanna show you something.
And, you know, recently we talked
to Jennifer Love Hewitt on "ET".
And she was absolutely glowing about an amazing experience
that she recently had, check this out.
I just did Drew Barrymore's show.
And I have been literally,
like she's everything to me personally.
I just love her so much.
And we really had such a good time.
And like, I feel like we had sort of
like a heart soul connection.
And after the interview, she sent flowers to my house
and said, let's be friends, let's do this.
Let's take this out of this business
and let's be people who are in each other's lives.
And I mean, I think I cried for two hours straight.
When there's somebody that you admire, you look up to,
and they take time for you.
Or they're a person who just reaches
out to you at the right moment.
It's beautiful.
(audience clapping)
I did and she did.
And it's on, we're becoming friends.
I'm really looking forward to getting to know someone
who I've loved from afar for so long, but it's on.
Oh Drew, that is so cool.
We love you, Kevin.
You're on "Entertainment Tonight" every weeknight.
(upbeat music)